because but i feel like women take
things so differently like you know like
even as a female i could go up to
another female like say i'm not really
friends with him like you know what your
hair's sticking up here well i think ego
is such a big thing for a female yeah oh
yeah i think people always put ego on
men no honey it's females as well and i
feel like they're like what do you mean
like they're just straight on smoke and
it's not i think why are you on sleep
i'm actually trying to help you i've
said women don't like women generally
yeah i i agree like women and it depends
on the country like other women because
because women are women's competition
and so
if you if i said if you were to bring
another three women in here yeah right
the women will be like analyzing these
women like you know [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
right so women generally don't like
women did that happen when i came late
who the [ __ ] is this girl yeah they look
at them as companies
don't get twisted men do the same i said
when men men's competition for another
man
is different from a woman's country
because a man will a man will look at a
man's
success
when we look at men as a man we look at
another defined success all right so you
look at jay-z or puff daddy or warren
buffett or let's bring it down
a man a man will look at another man's
success and maybe be envious of his
success yeah we don't generally i'm not
saying it doesn't happen we don't
generally look at other men and be like
look at his look he's look at what he's
wearing i don't think you're what's he
wearing why is he wearing that
i'm saying generally i'm saying
generally like i'm not saying men don't
do it but men don't look at other men
and think oh my god look at his hair
what what okay look at his boots
women do that women look at other
women's shoes and get jealous of that
[ __ ] and start doing that i can not be i
don't care
like you said generally yeah generally
there are some that don't but
i've i've experienced some men that do
and but it's not the
vast majority but i do agree with you
that
i feel like women
not all women but some women are more
materialistic so what we see is what
we're going to analyze we're not going
to think about anything else because we
don't see that we don't know what's
going on we don't care about that but
men are like okay like
i don't they just don't think about
looks it just like doesn't cross their
mind to be like that man looks better
than me another nice looks and they just
they just
act the way they act i would say that
a man can correct me for wrong they
would be
more intimidated or not even intimidated
but analyze a person's personality and
how they carry themselves
more than
women would all right so this is the
thing if a man
if a man walks in a room right
and
women flock towards that man like they
go
like the other men are thinking oh
who the [ __ ] is he like
what's going on with him like does he is
he someone that i don't know
and
we might look at that and wonder to
ourselves why is he getting the female
attention that we're not getting right
but we don't look at
generally
his looks we're one we're wondering
what is it about this man
that has all the women going towards him
and normally it's success yeah
you know what i mean like normally it's
confidence i find that men more like
how they dress i feel like it's sort of
funny
yeah like the character characteristic
so how you portray yourself do you know
what it's image let me let me actually
get down to it it's actually image like
how you portray yourself like because
when you say when it comes to social
status
social status i don't know you yet so
it's like i could be attracted to you
and it's like
i don't know you okay i'm sorry
see you walk into the room i could be so
attracted to you but it's like that's
not based on the person i don't know who
the hell you are
like but that's just me looking at you
how you dress
me personally how you dress how you look
how you like maybe carried yourself into
the room that like you're over your
energy but it's not me like saying oh
that's your personality that's just
looking at you but that's like but even
men they look at that and they're like
oh like that's how we dress they look
like materialistic stuff as well not
like women though
like look at this is the thing
like you you you no but you're you you
you're arguing something that's just
like you keep arguing for the exception
you do this all the time it's not the
rule like like
80 80 of like consumer debt is women 80
of consumer buying decisions is by women
right women buy most [ __ ] right
everything is marketed towards women
yeah yeah so that's like these are like
whatever it is women are violent yeah
that's what i'm saying like why argue
exceptions when we're talking about the
rule you know what i mean
but correct possibly a woman will look
at a woman's arms what are you going to
say and be like why is her uh why don't
you get her arms like that
women i think are better at cheating
than men are it's still messed up if
it's women are more detail-oriented men
tend to focus not on details another one
from sandra it's because women it's
sometimes because sometimes women might
rightfully be upset about something and
men just blame it on their period that's
actually good
he'll be like he'll he'll be like
we'll be like you cheated on me and he's
like you're just on your feet
no but
are you telling me as a man right
there's no argument we can have to say
that you're in your period just calm the
[ __ ] down
no not cheating
i'm not talking about cheating i'm
talking about i'm saying okay when we
as your man that we've been with you for
a prolonged period of time and we can
see your your
behavior changing at a certain point in
time
right they know your cycle are you
telling me that that's never an argument
for us no look at me yes you already
know
first of all you already know you're
crazy as hell
crazy
nobody look at me if you already know by
saying that that pisses the girl off
mm-hmm why would you want to do that
again because he's not trying to piss
you off okay but then if you already
know by saying that it pisses her off
yeah but
she's trying to like you know it just
makes her feel like what she what i'm
saying if you have a conversation and
he's saying like no i legitimately like
this is i think it's because you're on
your period i'm not trying to offend you
right and you have that information
getting upset is a choice
it's a choice
listen ali